oh [__] okay we said we were going to
get to this and we are going to get to
this well uh black Candace Owens
black Candace Jones treacherous [__]
this one
I'm gonna have to families and of course
extorting my very good friend Stephen
Crowder
the treacherous [__] why is she dressed
like Beetlejuice
the joke I made earlier merch was
somebody said the n-word three times and
she popped up
see I was gonna I was gonna say instead
of the Ghost with the most a different
word for ghost but anyway
yeah she looks kinda
spooky yeah she does that spooky it's
very spooky yeah
[Laughter]
all right guys come on
knock it off
wait so if she's Beetlejuice wait so
she's Beetlejuice Stephen Crowders
Jeffrey Jones right yes
referencing Federal people I've I've met
that she's a Fed oh yeah probably
so what's Beetlejuice
um I think you guys didn't mean that I
think what you meant was
just a beautiful black woman who's
defending herself from the terrible
attack from Stephen Crowder and the fact
that you're making fun of the way she
looks in a really big weird forehead is
pretty [__] up
you know it's not that big of a forehead
that's one thing it's just a weird angle
I've had people yell at me there's some
people out there here we go he's gonna
defend the [__] the black chick okay
come on yeah tell us about the black
chicks
Candace Owens is a walkable plaque yeah
she is yes she is I'll give you that
like and then everybody can I say can I
say yes yes I agree I will agree thank
you I said it today actually on day wave
she is hot and I would [__] her of
course and I can see through my hatred
of a woman in order to like [__] him
like I wouldn't you know what I mean so
it just makes me laugh sometimes that
there are people out there that will be
like oh she's ugly and I'm like you just
hate her and I get it I hate it I mean
personally she pulled her tits out a
hotel room you'd go nice and you
probably go for us well first off here's
what I would say here's what I would say
she pulled their tits out I thought
they'd be darker and then I go nice in
the nipples right the nipples the
areolas
that's true fact right out there folks
we don't know listen now don't say that
we don't know if she believes her
nipples confirmed facts only your
nipples yeah but only the strong Candace
dead center of the nipple so it kind of
Fades out no it's actually true she has
that weird [__] Michael Jackson Sammy
Sosa thing where she hates herself but
like only then you think you could [__]
her she's talking to you think you [__]
her can of someone's like no okay have
you tried being Charlie Kirk
if I had to Freaky Friday with Charlie
Kirk for one day to [__] her I still
would
yeah well like your depth perception to
be all [__] up because your face is so
little that's a good point you know what
I take it back I do want to be Charlie
Kirk for one day because I want to know
what it's like
to look at Charlie Kirk's face in a
mirror but through Charlie Kirk's
misplaced eyes yeah cause that must be a
mind fight because no it's it's it's
like pointing to Fun House mirrors at
each other you know yeah that's a good
point it's like a horse I wonder if he
looks normal
Nintendo 64 version like a polygon
he looks like when Mario gets too close
to the corner he looks like Flora Croft
he looks like he looks like Laura
croft's titties
oh I'm sorry Candace you were saying
he's now upping the ante and suggesting
that I extorted him I will not take that
life if he claims that I extorted him
I'll kill him
you know hey Candace hey Candace baby
it's not such a crazy claim that you
might have extorted somebody considering
that you made you you're you got famous
off of a website that extorted people
that was that was true
that was the website website it's the
foundation yeah I was the business model
he's now upping the ante and suggesting
I do judging off that clip she was not I
wouldn't say like you wouldn't be able
to she was being [__] she was just
being [__] but she was kind of going
like I'll be ashamed people found out
about you [__] you know what I mean it
was fun it's like let's put it this way
you you wouldn't be able to get Steven
on or you wouldn't be able to get her on
extortion and she wouldn't be able to
get him on defamation no because he's
not lying but I do want them both to
waste money
she mentioned also Virgie was reading it
that there was some texts that she
received from him that she was going to
put out where he would she goes in
retrospect they seem kind kind of flirty
now where he was kind of being a little
flirty with her now I don't I don't
believe that that's true because she
doesn't have a penis and I don't believe
that I don't believe that's true because
she's not a hunky lacrosse player and I
also don't believe that that's true
because she did that typical girl like
in hindsight like she didn't say you
know when I was like oh looking back on
it I was raped this is the right framing
yeah this sounds flirty right right
right
that I extorted him I will not take that
lightly okay I am not Hillary Crowder
and so
keep my wife's name out of your black
man you know we know you're not Hillary
Crowder because she's
insanely hotter than yeah
this morning after this clip was sent to
me if I contacted a defamation lawyer
and I am sending Stephen Crowder a cease
and desist and I'm going to demand is it
just me or just multiple camera angles
kind of detract from the you know you
don't need that many camera angles for
this kind of show no I don't I don't
understand why there's more it's
literally done so you go wow look we're
just like TV manned a full-throated
retraction to the idea
today Royce that's [__] twice
it's too easy and they're carting and
they're carting us off the field oh man
that was a bad one guys we were both
saying that he likes he potentially
might like to suck huge dicks all the
way down his bisexual High throw yeah I
don't think you'll understand what
full-throated means in regards to
Stephen Crowder idea that Candace Owens
threatened him more funny if he goes on
his next show at a guilty conscience and
look and now she's trying to even
further uh uh blackmail Me by trying to
imply that I'm gay and like nobody was
ever just joking nobody said you what it
won't say man like that is actually a
real phrase yeah Brian Callan Giggles in
the corner and goes huh you're not
I don't know if he's in the corner
because you can't sit Indian style in a
corner oh no they put him in the corner
after that it's crisscross applesauce
what clip what did he do wear a Crowder
yelled at him for what you guys didn't
see that no yeah Crowder yelled at Brian
Callan for [__] uh because Brian like
before they went live he [__] threw
his Instagram up and was like doing a
promo and [__] Steven walked past and
seen that he was filming and was like
what the [__] are you doing man I could
have been doing anything while that
camera was live
and he goes this is what I swear to God
the quote was this is why you get in
trouble this is why you get in trouble
here I'll pull it oh it's it's begun
I'll pull it it's begun
oh this Ark oh this Ark
here I'll do it on my phone so I can uh
distorted him so all right let's finish
this pink Candace clip Tim or X extorted
him so here's what I would like to do I
would like to invite Hillary Crowder
onto my platform because she doesn't
have one and oh this is petty yeah
coming on Candace can I can I say
something
she's not because she wants money she's
not going to but
I want to point out that and I know I I
don't mean to get but I have to because
we took so much [__]
we called this so long ago these people
are going to eat each other but not only
that these are the people that want to
be the no we're fighting we're fighting
mainstream conservatism we're different
we're Independent Media and you know
what you did you just turned into blood
Sports you just [__] turned in to
your drama feed you turned into what
everybody else on the internet
eventually turns into which is a [__]
drama channel so now daily wire and
[__] Crowder are [__] drama
channels that are fighting with each
other and going oh yeah oh yeah I'm
gonna have your girlfriend on I'm gonna
have a girlfriend on the only thing this
clip leads at the end of it is a text to
speech
it really does you know
and because her ex-husband apparently
just used his to insult her that's
because he picked the wrong woman he did
do that he did do that he did he did do
that and that to be really despicable it
really is true all roads on the internet
lead to internet blood Sports yeah they
all lead to the Coliseum baby
or if you are watching you are more than
welcome to come on my show and to talk
about what's actually going on
yeah that didn't make you look like a
petty piece of [__] you could have just
been like this is so good this is
delicious right it's the best it's the
this has been the best it's been one of
the best [__]
weeks hey guys hey guys I have a
question though why don't these guys you
know because they kept telling us for
years you know that why don't they just
have a conversation why don't we have a
conversation about the conversation why
doesn't Dave Rubin and his hair plugs
moderate the conversation why don't you
guys have a conversation no because we
have to have a conversation about that
conversation and then we all get calm we
all have conversations where we play
clips of the conversation
it's it's really just amazing to me it
really these people are uh I mean you
know and it's for anybody to say like
it's not like we were like oh the right
Wings grooved these are specific people
that we pointed out yeah from day one
and it's like they're all now they're
all killing each other and it's like
that's a good point it wasn't just like
we didn't just generically go everybody
we spent we said this this person this
person this person this person and and
and look at them this is what they are
now you're a bunch of [__] drama
streamers fighting with each other and
honestly there's not there's nothing
more beautiful to me than [__] daily
wire and Crowder two of the think the
worst the worst Bad actors the worst
[__] group of people going at each
other I don't believe these people are
genuine they get a lot of you and tell
you they're genuine you know what
mercifire piece of ship immersion aren't
going to make you buy 26 chocolate bars
all right so I mean I'm just saying that
these people doing this show you what
they really are this has got to be one
of the busiest news weeks that there's
been in a long time with Elon lemon
thing and the Tucker thing and the
Dominion
and instead of them putting their foot
down these these real journalists he's
putting their coverings they're fighting
with each other because so one of them's
getting divorced
what I mean what is that it's you know
what it is it's the tolerant right at it
again it's the tolerant right tolerant
right
the Free Speech rights slapping each
other with [__] lawsuits yep yes and
season decision
threats and again tell us whatever we
want we might we might not have a fancy
off glass office or whatever [__]
else we do but at least you get a focus
rate from US that's the one thing you
get from us you get the truth you get
what we think and that's it and it's not
going to be this political game that
every all these guys are so phony
they're so phony they fooled all of you
into thinking they were friends
they hate each other they've always
loved each other but you know everyone
wonders why me and Royce have done every
event we've ever done and we show up
with a certain level of just where we're
always aloof we're always very we're
always very open to shake anyone's hand
and say hello and be nice to them but
we're also not going to be like oh wow
I'm gonna network with this guy like
we've always just gone to places and
been like all these people are [__]
gay
[Music]
like this person [__] sucks but hey
be polite when they come over hey what's
up brick suit guy